I talked to z' day-night on a YouTube
livestream I did and again yesterday on
the broadcast show about some of the
bogus accomplishments and totally
fallacious policy ideas that Donald
Trump touted at his first address to
Congress on Tuesday evening we're now
better prepared to quantify the degree
to which Trump lied obscured and
distorted during that speech Trump gave
a 61 minute speech and told 51 lies 51
lies in 61 minutes the Center for
American Progress tallied up tallied it
up rather and tweeted about it this is
close too close to one lie per minute
when you average an applause time and
there were a number of very forced
applause lines during this speech it's
probably equal to about one lie per
minute alternative facts riddled
throughout this speech some of the
biggest lies which we've already
discussed on the show Trump distorted
unemployment numbers Crump study
inherited an economic disaster from
Obama just read a report today jobless
claims at their lowest point in 44 years
close to what is considered full
employment in economic terms more than
doubling the stock market etc etc I
suspected that Trump was lying when he
said that most terrorists in the US
since 9/11 were born in other countries
that is just absolutely untrue in fact
check time and again since speech Trump
saying that the corporate tax rate in
the US is of the highest in the world
also not true Trump taking credit for
stock market gains that didn't take
place under his administration they took
place under President Obama's Trump
claiming that he drained the swamp quite
the opposite and Donald Trump saying
that he is responsible for the
withdrawal from TPP you can't really
withdraw from something that you haven't
signed on to in the first place and of
course from a political perspective
American involvement in TPP was dead
dead by late October or early November
some of the other lies in misleading
statements that we didn't have time to
get to on Wednesday's segment because
there are just so many Trump said that
the Keystone and Dakota access pipelines
will create tens of thousands of jobs
wrong sad low-energy most of the jobs
will be temporary and it's estimated
that Keystone pipeline for example
we'll create only about 35 permanent
jobs 35 tens of thousands not a rounding
error folks not a rounding error
Obamacare is collapsing well millions of
people with low and middle incomes have
obtained health insurance because of the
Affordable Care Act otherwise they
wouldn't have been able to afford it is
that a collapse not really and you have
to consider the lot of the shakiness and
uncertainty surrounding Obamacare has
been because of the criticism and
threats to repeal it from Republicans
and people like Trump and again we still
haven't been offered the real
alternative claims about undocumented
immigrants that undocumented immigrants
cost the country billions of dollars the
truth is a number of reports have looked
into this immigration in the long run
doesn't actually cost the u.s. anything
you have the children and grandchildren
of immigrants who actually add add to
the economy to the tune of 224 billion
dollars which heavily outweighs the
costs completely false and debunked
notions about criminality etc and Donald
Trump saying that over 43 million
Americans are on food stamps that's
technically true but that number
declined under President Obama as the
economy improved so really what he's
saying is although the numbers are down
during Obama they're still high if you
look at where george w bush handed over
the economy to barack obama it's bad pat
i mean it is bad and the trumpets don't
care 51 lies in 61 minutes they liked
the tone though PolitiFact looks into
trump's suspicious claims that he makes
from time to time
yeah and seventy percent of the time
they find that his claims are just
flat-out false yes and i think that has
to do a lot with the fact that he's just
not very knowledgeable on a lot of
different topics and he's not add a bit
of a liar also he really is he does
obvious lies rather than politician lies
where you can just look it up and know
he's not telling the truth well this is
perhaps worse I think because it's a
prepared speech he's reading off of a
teleprompter so his staff is crafting
something up that will make him able to
mislead the public intentionally that's
a whole nother layer there absolutely
distorting along those same we're using
that same tactic when it comes to the
crime and murder rates and I mean we've
debunked most of the lies individually
over the last year to year and a half
but when you cram 51 of them into 61
minutes it's uh there's almost not
enough time to fact-check and actually
we've talked about this before it's not
even that effective to fact-check
because the rational people know that
he's lying and the committed trumpets
don't care so it's almost like an
exercise in futility in a way I mean
especially if there's no real like
zingers or just clear sound bites that
you can kind of take out from the speech
yeah I mean this is well delivered
well-written so people are just going to
take it on face value and not look any
further into it yeah strong leader very
very strong leader just amazing
tremendous what he's able to do send me
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show